all right we're live
all right no doubt
see if I can get that thing
nope
really yep
huh that's so weird
so when you join all because you already
joined the room as him
I I think so you might that like I think
you're gonna
you might have to
[Music]
try that
okay
foreign
[Music]
no one shot
I could just create a role in here just
create another room
yeah okay I'm sorry guys oh you're fine
no you're good you're good
all right
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I hope you don't fear pain so
so his his power is absolutely
ridiculous
you've played them already you tried
them no I'm looking at his like his
cards his cards
yeah the jump I've seen the jump move
was crazy I haven't seen any of those
other bulldog
so I have my headset at full charge for
the battery pack is Up full charge and
I'm sitting with a USB
yeah I got the plugs ready to go look
just in case I have a I have a six foot
extension on my on my
um USB right my USB is uh what's up my
USBC is what's up live Supremacy
baby
um it's six feet
and I have I have my 12 foot uh
extension cord with a with the power
supply sitting next to me so I have that
extra six feet I tweeted it from the way
I don't accidentally
you treated it yeah go ahead
can be here can you hear us oh yeah I
don't I never give you guys
same as before you know I mean
thoughtful oh I feel you the thing is is
that we are a little bit more loose with
language and stuff for these because
they're not they're not like IOP
[Music]
obviously we don't want to be like
cussing out in the rain but
yeah yeah
I can't what we censor like language and
stuff for for other reasons it's not
necessarily for like the community like
so I that's why I wasn't
it's mainly just being I can't talk I
can't speak right now oh it's I'm trying
to say something
I'm stuttering over my own words I'm
trying to say something in my mouth is
not letting me say it
foreign
it's mainly just we want to be anyone to
be able to listen to us at any time
without like worrying about anything
right and I understand that
people are posting the games that we
played on our Twitter yeah
hello
so you'll be
you know
the weapon has my name in it
foreign
no the hook of Varga
you stupid I am dead serious
sister both of my name the uh on the
road
on the road though like his is it the
first number or the second number that's
his damage I think it's the second right
oh that's good
the second number might be his like the
the link that he has
I can't remember
I shall
or critical maybe maybe
I just Waters
what are you trying to get what's
interesting
I was trying to do it in desktop mode
but it kept just re-downloading the
update so I had to go oh so you had to
have the update that's what it was I I
keep doing it over and over nine gigs
over and over
really interesting yeah
playing this on a PC for the win
yeah all right give me a second I just
want to I'll promote the screen
[Music]
you're losing the immersion when you
play on PC I don't care about none of
that immersion
you care about coffee yeah
I don't know I'm quite comfortable with
this VR headset on can we do Among Us
after this
I I it's his birthday
I would pull out the the Oculus for
Among Us
[Music]
oh
now that I have the two well I don't
know if uh attic plays it I know the two
of you definitely don't play WoW
look at this place
wow
[Music]
it's like a little village
so I would like us though there's a
point of interest in a shop or something
yeah I see
there's two of them
get my tanky self over this all right
Chad I will live and die this this
company because I honestly feel like
this company made this on like like a
like a small small budget imagine they
had some money money behind them
oh
check your mail though are you a sell
sword
I don't know there's a dude in the Town
Square like a business
I remember you could you could you could
hire people in this one
yeah yeah something like that maybe I'm
wrong but I remember something like that
all right let me try this you know
there's a healing Fountain right here
let me try this grappling hook
it's the card that constantly like
redoes it
oh that's his intrinsic yeah yep
so I saw this guy on Tick Tock where he
was able to put the the chat above his
thing and then nobody sees it though but
him oh that's crazy
is that a bad guy yeah yeah he said get
over here what is this Vortex says
manifest all a minor Vortex which pulls
enemies
yeah I got that two cards yeah it's like
a new card
cognito
what up
now that now that I got you guys here I
would like us to take one day
right tonight though
great I love I would love for us to play
Conan in one day no I have no problem
not playing command awesome
I got you that's the easiest that's the
easiest Christmas present I can ever
give you
thank you so much
laughs
I respect that
well at least she went after somebody
yeah she got something
who will find the courage within wait I
don't have you
I only had one go what the
did they change my card number
you only have one going Carla
yeah
oh no I moved my character that's right
you moved your character that was the
yeah that was a joke
Elvin Spearman Cog what's up
um I don't know if you guys missed this
or not but you might want to check your
the IOP email there's something from
Chase there you know what I mean it's
something that popped up when we was in
LA I mean uh New York I just saw it when
I went to the emails
I mean it was from last night so I'm
sure solves already handled it but just
in case yeah okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
kill this guy over here okay go for it
they messed up
all right card
s into manifesting money
oh God am I courageous oh Elvis what are
you doing
oh he's doing some dirty movements
oh the Mystic more people towards us
they up to something they up to some
bull stuff man
yeah already
stopping my feelings all right let y'all
know what time it is
all right Big Buddy big money nowhere
it's nowhere
nice
foolishness I think I saw him oh dude he
got shot
oh somebody ran
he's like four of them four of them
oh
let's go got that crate
let's finish him off and we get good
all right let me try something
get over here
Easter you can pull him yep yep he said
die now uh someone in the chat said the
beggar swamps a card with you
like they call that guy a beggar yeah
that's what someone in the chat says
chill well I said hunting on Connor you
saw that it's a new uh thing on her what
is it why does it say
[Music]
yeah
it's dead
also I don't have to go at
oh they fixed it they fit Kana is now
they fixed but they fixed what now
Connor is not immune to Blinded confused
charm friendly and panic remember we
used to complain that Conor would just
do whatever Connor wants to do but now
yeah you can make it focus on someone so
it won't attack the people you don't
want them nice she's actually good for
uh uh prolonged boss damage
are you going to play high on life
sometime next week uh tomorrow's the
last IOP but I'll be streaming
throughout the whole vacation
because without no podcast doing I have
more time
find the courage Within
[Music]
courageous
so you guys might see like me
you guys like see like me and um like
King maybe playing fortnite throughout
the vacation but there won't be no
podcasts
[Music]
oh I'm over here
someone said one of the nvcs gives you
gold oh
yeah
oh
how'd he hit me what did I do because
he's throwing up he's throwing some
Vortex what was that yo you support
something called the what a minor
summoning Rift Elvin Elvin Summoner
he's immune to stun
Frozen tangle Panic blinded charm
confused big ability blocker corrupted
corrupted rage someone was spawn
something in a couple of turns if we
don't get it out of here so anyways yeah
and he has
summon riff teleportation telekinesis
push
God
telekinetic push deflect Fair
and deflect back get them summons out
there's one behind by the board over
here everybody is you better check that
out too all right let's see what's this
look at this Mystic
I can get this seriously
oh which one this one right here
over there okay
let me work on a Mystic first and then
did that
I don't know if that it looked like no
no it's just dude in the back yeah it's
a dude Elvin Summoner this yeah right
here yeah this dude right here I wonder
if you killed the summer we'll stop all
those
ability summon ref yeah summon ref
teleportation telekinetic push and yeah
he over here he over here in the back
you see him how you mark them
oh God way over there right now yeah you
can't kind of wish I went with my hunter
instead of Connor yeah
we need that long distance DPS oh no oh
you got a bench
oh
of course I missed
crit oh there you go
oh let's go
he said if we use the vortex dust it'll
kill them in one hit
really oh I see the person who got the
key yo this little Bandit got the key to
Thug over here you see him
[Music]
um
okay
[Music]
oh it's my turn all right
um let's see
I'm going to who's next
on blast
you have that Vortex dust he said you
could throw it at him and it'll work
Whitehead killer I don't know about the
vortex I think he was talking about the
gates
okay
I can't hit him
so I'm gonna move up here
and I'm gonna give you
don't fear any phone
[Music]
appreciate that courage
ous
get that coverage helping me out right
now there's a there's a dude coming over
a goblin Ranger coming out this side
over here
here let me get I said I want to get the
Mystic out because he's going to cause
problem then I'm gonna see what this
cell sword do
you think about big money no whammys
all right cool all right let's see what
your man over here what he do at the
shop
Hollis we can hire him
soy join your team I'm Arley and if you
feel you're in dire need of a loyal so
you're not gonna fight you're just gonna
stand there until we get to go
yo yep your man is out of pocket and I
love how they're not attacking him
they're just letting him sit there yeah
they just they
die in a town square but for 200 beans
I could be it's cold to you there's gold
here yeah I know I get the gold over
here
oh yeah that doesn't look good yep
he's definitely out of pocket
yeah he's not gonna fight
oh I like how you can pull them like
that that's crazy
[Music]
and scratch
in the squash
I like how it says hunting yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna stick my neck out
can I hit him
um
I'm gonna do something nobody else has
done
bravery I'm gonna give Canada some
courage concur which means monster
small so we can keep her alive yo oh
that Mystic is moving the thing over
there that's weird
keeping him alive
ow
there's another cell swords doing the
like
I wonder if it's probably the bigger
if we um if you if you get them do they
stay throughout the entire experience or
is it just for this level no I think it
would be the whole thing
to me if it was just one thing he would
be like 50 coins or 100 200 is a lot you
know what I'm saying it's a lot yeah he
better be I want a paid contractor
you know what
come on home
wow
come kinda
[Music]
come Donna
Unleash Your rest holy shirath
I love that it says hunting
[Music]
heed my call
we're about to find out soon who's going
to win that bet between me and King
which was better Spider-Man being on
PlayStation 4 or PlayStation 5 only
because he said it's gonna be a
crosstalk huh yeah I think you're gonna
win that because I think they said it's
gonna be pf5 only the moment the moment
that's confessionally confirmed he's
done
sorry yeah what will the themes do
it's okay I can take it because other
people can't
oh my God
I kind of want to use these other
abilities and try them out yeah you need
to check them out because we need to
know how effective they are
uh what we got what we got
I got so much of this dusting let me put
some in the paint I need some cards give
me a second
so many of these all right we should get
a car right now y'all okay
cool
all right
all right let me get in the mix badly
hurt your enemies might cause confusion
oh so I got something called the
Leviathan mechanical device that pulls
enemies close
nice it's like a kunai with Shane
nice that's definitely a scorpion that's
definitely a scorpion's uh
-huh
scorpions
all right so if you use the vortex it
pulls them in and it does one damage let
me test it I need to test this one touch
thing see how it worked
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you guys there
yeah it healed me that move heals me oh
really okay nice and I still
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay
[Music]
drop that boy up
[Music]
courage is what will save us marriage is
what we'll save us
um
[Music]
why scream like this
I stabbed them in the butt
what's going on what's that summoning
ritual thing going
cheers
summoning more windows yeah like that
foreign
I'm concerned that we need to take some
things out quick
I was doing this opens
huh opens a rift that summons unearthly
minions from another realm if not
destroyed
so in other words kill this thing or
we're going to really make you win yes
exactly well at least I got a critical
after the miss
there's a chest near me too ah he's in
your counter now
yeah stop hurting Kana
rammed you grabbed him up took a movie
come over and let's talk
[Music]
um
yep I'm just trying to fix the
[Music]
[Music]
should I destroy the portals or go after
him destroy the portals
hmm
I don't know what those spoilers do and
I'm not willing to sit around and find
out
we're gonna we're gonna end up not
killing the Porto and he summons many
many hymns everywhere like
steak and scratch
Steve let's rock
Olympics got seven Health that's crazy
nobody close enough to me so I won't do
that no no
check the finish off that portal bro
yeah
we don't want to know what come out of
that
there you go nice meet my dagger
see
I'm right there
well I won't reach them
how many hit points did you guys have
he has one he has three
I'm gonna hit these two guys right here
come on doubles
I like that
oh I did hit him oh you're wrong daddy
oh he took his shave gotta get him
holy skull he spawned to Druid master
because I didn't kill that thing in time
Druid houndmaster came out at that
stupid portal uh let's kill him
look at this courageous
you
like to bring dogs out here damn with
the messes today
oh it's a
yeah
[Music]
this thing is gonna be my damn card back
get over here yeah he robbed
this is nice
that's Beastie how he could pull up like
that though that is be in his control of
the raw bro
that's my change
in the back
scream their heart I was like I was like
you think you're getting away
where you going where you going
I'm like slow-mo and then this morning
on Halo I got my chain back
[Music]
oh
kind of up on level two all right all
right
yeah I get her to level three
[Music]
get a little Goblin wings
foreign
test could go that far
well to a certain point it goes to a
certain point but I was able to get the
I was actually able to hit to hit it so
yeah okay that was good
uh I can't see anybody else so I'm going
to hit go braver than you think
[Music]
I'm actually gonna have to get attic
with some courage though because he's
his health is getting low
yep
oh it's still my turn oh okay my bad
they said they said the guardian your
character the Barbarian God they have
good Synergy I guess you pull them and
then I can tank and you can rough them
up together kind of vibe
I'm going to move closer
yo we gotta get him out of here he get
on my nerves
we got to get he's going to continue to
do this and he it's him moving around
the map oh I don't like him already we
got to get him out of here
48 isn't hitting
yeah
yes 48 that's like boss level
yeah
a minute one and two turns
all right let's get a little bit warm is
okay I need this crap now come on now
I'm Gonna Come
before
let me kill him now
oh actually can I get in this part young
in this spot I had a lot of Fire
don't get you
yeah look at the ball
go back to the abyss
he really he said he's dead too
you just killed him in the cold blood
the penny the man there's one behind you
Eric
has anybody doing up here five or ten
Volcan five or ten we might need to get
to that um that potion so oh if it's too
heavy you can't pull it it's too heavy
it put me to it yeah pull you to it yeah
you can't pull it
and there's one behind you that's going
to spawn I want to turn two
are you gonna get the pleasure now and
then oculate or
I think I
would say kill it and then get the
poster or oh you you should potion I had
no choice I had three health I was gonna
die
oh
so you should have got the potion at
that point you should just walk over to
the Fountain and save the potion
yeah usually I do nothing but buy
potions with my money feed my call
let's do something started next time
[ __ ] scores problems babe oh hell
here blowing up stuff
kind of guarding the back
soon
[Music]
oh she did but
good courageous oh yeah let's get him
protected because he got mad beef over
there
[Music]
about to get a card too
yeah
see that courageous is now making the
damage lower
see he's able to tank because of that
courageous
yeah that's fine I
it's good I try I try to stay close to
people but
look it's not it's not your fault I can
like hop across the mat this is not you
I just brought the closest
bro you saw that
what summon a fire in the elementary
this time it's random enemies coming out
of the important bro them portals is a
problem yep yep let me get us a card
let's go all right I dipped one okay I
didn't need that gas lamp so if someone
else does something we can get another
card
all right cool
um
[Music]
oh that strength is giving me like if I
have a Purge on me
I said no it's Cognito from the West
you're really good I said the reports
are true
[Music]
I wonder what did he got any area of
effect I know that jump is an area of
effect card if you have a jump thing
[Music]
oh there it is that's the joke that
joint is crazy
oh look who's here your man Alvin
Summoner it's all when I see him he's
immune to stunning Frozen Tangled marked
you tried to pull him but you go okay so
there's a weight involved it said too
heavy that's buddy yeah and then when
it's too heavy I go to them
you go to them yeah
we'll jump them I'm right next to you
when I don't mind when it's my turn
well so much for my idea
using courageous him or he's going to
song recover him
I was gonna courageous
but oh well
I'm gonna go over here and get try to
get rid of this uh portal careful though
because you're gonna be dolo if it come
if it's four I think it's gonna spawn
next turn
I would rather you staying with sin it
only has three pinpoints so
you care when's the turn when's to turn
someone
no I don't have pepper
paprika
it uh this turn
it could spoil anything out there you
might not make it close enough to hit it
we're gonna take one turn to get the end
one turn ahead
come on we got a tough board
that part is tough get a bar let them
know let them know your name
get on board and do your thing
toss a coin took your part
there you go party into his business
it's again
oh wait they got the Unseen yeah yo this
dude is like one of the last level dudes
next to the public Alvin Queen trick
where's the Unseen right next to you
yep that's what I worry about
oh they got Connor
wow how much damage does he do four
one hit
they go out playing and jumping that
dude that dude got a party
I gotta repent
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
attic actually you can
you can broadcast the um
the among us as well because I can give
send you a link
[Music]
everybody's healed yeah apologize
yes very clutch thank you we need help
what is it a Harley owl what'd he do he
got Mirage he got out he got healing
potion
Panic powder he got a lot of yeah right
for 200 that sound good let's see it in
action now
they got healing I wonder if he can heal
us well I'm sorry
how much money do you guys have
we broke 59. yeah but I still got my
259. I don't I have zeros it's not gonna
give me any money
but you never picked up no money yet
I thought he gave it to all of us that's
why I remember
I thought so too but it looked like it's
individual because I stopped throwing
about 250. I have 259. yeah I got I got
259 too well that's weird though yeah
what's up Harry maybe you just glitched
I don't know
anyway you don't got no money
if you look on my stream I have zero
that's weird
[Music]
how much money do you have um sinister
[Music]
soon
[Music]
I stepped away for a second
you must have
all right
I just had a soda next to me and I
almost knocked it over
how much money do you have oh 59.
59 or 259. uh just 59. we just spent
200.
00
I got yo he threw three reps over here
bro y'all we got one two three four
I gotta go get him
y'all y'all gonna have to handle these
reps yeah because he he get them under
he threw five of them
yo all right damn it is a lot of them
for me to go leave though
should I go chase him
at the same time no I don't have any any
area effect cards right now
[Music]
this one's three I could kill one of
them and then then go but I wanted to
get them should I get him or should I
stay and get rid of the riffs I'm going
through the gate and it depends what's
fun
huh
you should have dealt with him earlier
should we should I go after him in this
room
try to try to get money and kill rest
because I'm gonna I'm gonna go for the
end of the level I have to keep
I'm talking about not the end of the
love I'm talking about dude that keep
teleporting
what are we gonna do about I'm Gonna
Keep moving all around and making these
riffs okay I think attic thinks he's
gonna skip by him
well he's probably gonna teleport you're
not on your invisible invisible Ninja
but at least if I'm if I get to him now
and he move I'll have a beat on him in
this area and y'all in the other areas
yeah I was trying to like pin him down
we're not near him at all
wait I could throw a behemoth here
though
yeah
I'm gonna throw up the game man I'm
gonna put it like right here just in
case he's moving all around and both
sides so yeah right here
I thought that's what we what I bought
that guy for so that we can go around
the map collect some money
laughs
the Behemoth can help out on the um the
Rifts yep
all right let's back
and she can't kill nothing
this will cause some ache
unleash train
ER one down Connor get some work
oh take that okay
healing water I got my healer Ward let's
go
[Music]
couple of situations
[Music]
yeah let's start working on that one
yeah
all right you want me to hit it again
you want me to to uh encourage you
or if you hit it again you won't kill it
unless you get a crit and then you got
you could you could kill the minor
summoning riff with one hit though
yeah
yeah
[Music]
nice this ends now
but he was killed him see
I am so glad I moved all right let's see
what your man doing you're doing
something he got a timer
what is he oh he got a barrier up what
does it mean yeah like yo he just made
himself
incoming spells in protection it's just
deflection it's not you could marry him
oh okay so it's not like physical damage
yeah
yeah we gotta start the hitting we gotta
start the beating
money so whammys come here
at least starting to hit him
getting on my nerve
so he's an anti-magic dude with that
barrier
why would he want to bury I can't see
his abilities can you see his abilities
uh yeah
it's so weird ability summon riff
teleportation telekinesis push and
deflect barrier
[Music]
yeah what's the deal with this one
that's that's the beggar I think right
we got to see what he wants
nice
sure
nice
on camera
I think I do have 202 some because uh I
saw the gold 259 or something like that
and then just went back down
yeah it's probably some glitch
I think I only see it on my tip my turn
oh okay
you want me to come towards y'all or you
want me to head towards soon
go towards Lord yo the cell sword don't
move he just stayed in that same spot
has he done anything I'm looking I'm
trying to see if we getting this 200
worth of action
so let's move three
I didn't see that man move yet I saw him
shoot once he shot okay yeah
I guess you come towards us eh
all right
he's like if I don't see the beef around
me I'm not going towards it yeah make it
out of courageous
we move around the map he could be in
danger more than all of us oh no wrong
yeah that was definitely the wrong one
damn that's a man powerful you messed up
you've been simple strong recovery
I can't believe it look at this look at
oh he's a sucker he's a sucker I hate
her
well I guess check this guy what he does
I'll check it yeah oh the man ran off
I am so mad right now
wow yeah you wasted a powerful card do
you want to open this door I can try to
get us out of here
um we don't got enough money there's
nothing in it
I mean we could do that let me just see
what this dude do though I need I need
to know what he does
okay he says the governor I I could hope
he could Aid us
take this oh he's just gonna give me
something
right except what oh he's just giving me
money oh all right so he's a good thing
I listen and just spoke to him
he said help our town please
help us
we about to bounce yeah
[Music]
he gonna get that going you're gonna get
that gold on the way
[Music]
come
I think that thing can only attack or um
mm-hmm defend I mean attack or move I
don't think you do in the same turns
because every time it moves it doesn't
put up portals
yeah definitely whenever they see drama
they run
I want to get this gold before we leave
yeah yeah definitely definitely
definitely we're gonna need it we're
gonna need better cards we got a chess
over here as well
I guess I'm in the bank so you just want
to try to get some better cars getting
rid of this votech stuff that I don't
need
foreign
just put something in there too
it will save us thank you
he in the dark he'd like to throw the
portals
where did they come from
the portals over here
so I don't get the key so I can't should
I just head towards it or you just open
it
yeah all right
just to see what's in there
[Music]
all right cool
[Music]
and they can start heading back you can
come up this way all the way
yeah that's true oh no there's a chest
he's right and there's money nice oh he
could grapple to the goal that's fire
that's just his regular ability yes
that's crazy
appreciate it Peter MC try planting us
now yep he said happy birthday
oh that's what's up
[Music]
this will cause some ache
boy I can thank you
[Music]
he just fired
oh gosh
[Music]
I'm gonna run in
as you know
yeah you might not wonder that let me
run it fine yeah thank you and then you
let me right here you know how we do yep
I protect my bards
okay monster time oh yeah you're gonna
be in the shadows to do it
I like how he popping off like that like
setting off these Rockets bro
he's moving all over the place
oh yeah
yeah he went right next to the beginning
so he can get ahead with all that
yeah all right I'm going oh God
I'm good all right yes
it's cash we like cash
749 we like cash
motion
no that's good those are permanent no
I'm saying what you call it
what do you get
an oil lamp
S
no but I heard laughs at him are good
I read something with him and lamb so
good
you should get that cash in the web or
you want to go this way get these get
these two caches and then we'll head out
that way
thank you
oh I see what you're doing that was free
nice
oh no I can I'm trying to level what up
before the next round unleash pain
she's so close
oh he's working on it okay he shot the
thing okay he don't move though
[Music]
oh it's my turn
he's like
yeah I'm not impressed with him right
now
let's see let's hope he goes raise this
yeah that's what I want to know for that
200 you better travel brother
I like the moment
[Music]
it's not oh no we got to get out this
board soon because like I don't got the
key so I can't live
wait for you to guard the back
I'm just gonna hold down there
are we gonna leave that gold over there
let's go
that's to this yeah
that's every time I start making my way
there's another [ __ ] uh bad guy that
shows up blocking the path
over there with just a grappling hook
but then I would take me a minute to get
back
which I wouldn't do right
yeah we should just leave bro what is
that reptilian it's drama that you don't
need so Leslie
exactly okay
it looks heavy well before we do um
don't buy nothing
I'm Gonna Save and leave it and give the
room coats we have the data
be right back
selection
come on man
who's next Who's Next hosts assistant to
even leave
I'm leaving
because he's
because he saved and left right yeah
why does it say save and leave for me
yes you do that press that please
8653
save and leave save and leave
nothing out of you you have it next
ah customers and the Lions too welcome
[Music]
foreign
uh we gotta repeat in the list though we
got enough strength potion
the double over the stroke that's crazy
magic potions are here I wish they would
let me use these first these potions
right now instead of having to go into
you yeah I know to clear up space I know
where the piercing
fully heals all party members
that's big I'll be there for the crew
then if I take that before
but yeah I mean that's really important
I'm 94.
I'm here
dilemma dilemma
it's of God decision
yeah
I'm like I wish they would let me use
this strip
ES
they don't understand
I don't see him
wings
[Music]
well that's a good potion
increase your right Max Health by three
what the fatality that's huge yeah
that's you are you better use that you
better pick that up
I got it that's huge
yeah I got another physical strip
I can't buy any more cards
I got that in a swift motion
10 out of 10 cards a swift potion on top
of the the grappling hook I have
yeah it's gonna be crazy
so it was sinister
mm-hmm
he looked at the cold
Ness
he said he'll be right here he said he'd
be right there he probably went to the
bathroom so
[Music]
foreign
I wonder
do I get a bathroom oh God
all right B I did some really beasty
stuff what you did
I plugged in my battery pack
I wasn't plugged in before
no I'm like I plugged it
oh wow you're playing okay
there are so many there's a strength
potion in here
there's a water flask
there's Heaven's Fury
I can't buy none of it because I'm all
out of spots
have experienced a good card
I can get there's two of them here
[Music]
so what I picked up was the Vitality
potion
and then I picked song of resilience
oh
summons magical armor that protects your
eyes that's super important that's great
for boys so I'm sitting here looking I'm
like I'm looking at all of them and
they're like you know I gotta get it
mm-hmm
so you know what cards you want
we got them
we're waiting on you
oh you spent oh that's right my bad
nevermind
I wish I could give other people
I wish I can donate money to help other
people get cards too you know
like add it to a kitty for like the
party
yeah
no seriously
one of these
is what we do in dungeon dragons we we
there's party Loop and then there's your
loot and then party Loop
like so if if we get like a set amount
of gold
we divvy it up and whatever is extra
goes into a kitty
so that way if anything happens where
somebody's like oh I'm short I'm short
so much well we'll take it out of the
kitty
mm-hmm
I don't drink anything and I gotta use
the bathroom over and over yeah I know
that yeah I set myself well away if we
had to shoot
no I'm good are you ready ready to
stay ready
it just says me and you shopping but I
read it up everyone ready
but by delving deeper into ends you can
sense that there's new diabetic medicine
makes me use bathrooms oh he came with
us the dude came
he did yeah he's right behind let's hope
yeah instead of staying in one damn spot
um
yeah get the gold we're gonna get the
gold
I wonder if Sinister has to move him
no I haven't touched him he's been going
on his own oh hold on I got the defense
potion let me start using these photos
I can only use these potions on my turn
right
no I think
man Carl you you do hit like what five
six right now each yeah yeah I got two I
had two of them and you know what's
crazy I could have bought a third
strength [ __ ] but I wanted to hear
all party members for the team
in one of my healing rules and I know
how I love my healing warts
I know y'all love my healing
oh he gained Max 3 HP oh he had 13 to
13.
damn this man this man
so if nobody where's Chrono if nobody
moves if nobody moves
for armor
[Music]
I tell you stupid you're an ass I could
have given us all armor yeah but it
don't don't waste it for this it's no
encounter you use that when we about to
beef up when we about to really take
something
[Music]
forever though right as long as you know
what it does but
I would I would you combine that with
stronger recovery when we really need to
be tanky
I think she couldn't come out because
the space was filled up with people
if I get another song of recovery sure
next time down because I use them this
is really Dilly since I stupidly
used one used one
I still that's still burning my britches
man I'm like I can't believe I burned
that card
it happens oh another Elemental okay
they're friends
scratch that dog and get the cash
[Music]
you know that barrier you could use for
the group not just you right see
yeah I'm just looking at everybody's
house real quick
that bear is actually real powerful like
you know you know we messed up with her
when we fight the last boss with the
hydras
[Music]
you know that boy with the hydrants and
the bar stabbing around yeah the tail
what you supposed to do with her is that
astral Berry that you have on now you
give that to the crew to all of us right
including yourself and every time at
that time I'm talking about back in the
day when we used to take her in there uh
so what happens is when you give that
astral barrier you can reflect
everything she deflect the poison dragon
spit and send it back to the Hydra she
makes the Hydra a joke
that part that you're using right now
that is super powerful I found out
so
who do I want to give this to who who I
want to give courage to First give it to
give it to um I'll give it to add it
because or me I mean
already a pound is already a Hound but I
got that I got armor I got I got
strength cards I would either give it to
sin or give it to um addict because I
had more time or sin because I keep
calling you keep calling a lot yeah
bravery
[Music]
um attic is out of my range
there you can head towards them or not
oh there go by Fresh Direct
good it's not my turn let me know when
it's my turn
all right
if you want me to come your way or
addict
yeah that's fine
all right
I'll head over with you
move stupid
[Music]
why can I not move
and it's not letting me move
foreign
[Music]
what's going on
that's what's going on
foreign
[Music]
we're on Oculus and stuff I don't know
you hear me can you hear me can you hear
me yeah yo yeah
so what happened
attic opened the chest while you were
gone
you lost that on a card
oh great
[Music]
that's crazy I don't want to sleep
that's annoying
nobody attacked this dog
I don't even know where my man is what
is my man doing you're right here oh
okay
nobody attacked this dog
[Music]
why cause you got a bone what
the hell was that
[Music]
I don't know yeah I got a ball to reveal
the path but I didn't reveal nothing
right here
this is the exit right here
so I revealed it revealed the exit
come Connor Unleash Your Wrath
come Connor
or attack the dog that I just said not
to attack don't attack yeah did he just
say don't attack the dog no I didn't
I'm about getting it tonight
clearly this man we could have had
another friendly
you're braver than you think
monster time
ah he's back oh yeah man so he gonna be
terrorizing this for multiple levels
oh man that left side just got keptic
foreign
yup
I hit hit him and it went in the spot
are you serious
line up and die
all right how am I gonna handle this
[Music]
you can leap over there can you jump
over there I don't have a leap
oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah helps innocent
something over here hurt me
I don't like that it was deep
it was the guy that that be killed
he tossed a Vortex dust oh
yeah I'm not feeling all all over here
yeah it was just like a stationary low
he has a movement of War oh I'm using it
for the um the forecast
nice very nice
there's still one here though we got to
kill that witch if he's going to keep
following us
they look like every dungeon this man's
gonna be all around that harass us to
the third level that'd be crazy if you
don't kill him now you fight him and
divorce
sting and scratch
oh damn Connor's down to level one or
she's not alone so
she's at four to two too
uh Cog so I was asking a question in the
IOP trap
[Music]
really they won't let me
[Music]
know you're braver than you think
[Music]
[Music]
um
I think I'm gonna stay right where I'm
at
oh There He Go yeah buddy
no he moved into this corner
he moved he was right here he went like
this and then shot over this way
who you're talking about
he moved and shot
I'll skew
oh oh
let me see something
wait he's full health again
wow he's like crazy new map new me
yo you're stupid
cool it's always on my clutch Bros it
always happens bro
I think it's the first time I've ever
seen a bad clutch throw hit the the
target you wanted it anyway
oh
foreign
[Music]
I know
oh we got somebody over here
oh we're supposed to be using that one
Tank's dust uh for her
to pull collecting close to us
maybe it'll stop uh the thing from
teleporting teleporting We Gotta Throw
the dust on that thing
that's what I should have did
screw this
I got one buddy I can probably move by
the time it's going to
I have one as well
[Music]
yeah but you probably got a lot to say
right
[Music]
can you use it
I can
try and I'm gonna
do it
Dodge this
domestics
bravery
thank you
oh he moved and shot the thing
but he didn't damage the portal what the
hell
oh there's a Mystic behind him
oh hey he robbed you yeah I'm tired of
this losing stealing [ __ ]
[Music]
let's see
his attack is plus two while he has that
kid
[Music]
stupid thing is in my face it sucks
oh I could hit him oh
wait
oh no it can't
fall
no I can't
one block away that sucks let me try
something
he's completely blocking this stupid
Elemental
right
it's ridiculous
[Music]
I think that's the most damage
I think that's the most damage I've ever
seen anyone individually do
of like just the base attacks
you've gotten three double string cars
that is just insane
yeah it's crazy
[Music]
can't really do much of these people
that Thief took your card
yeah he's right here
pull them back
[Music]
[Music]
no no we don't we don't tolerate that in
the house of the iron Lords okay
you know what
my book heals
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
nice
all right now I can move out
don't fear any phone
thank you
[Music]
nope I'm not gonna do that
can I hit this over here
you know what I think a simple song of
Silence
immune to Ability block he
is
[Music]
but the other one the elvenar
yep
cool
courageous
oh no
that doesn't look well for me
what happened them two trying to jump
you three oh four man people over there
all right what a mysticated brat so I
can help you out over here
so you got an Elven cultist in front of
you too but really it's not a threat in
the I'd rather protect you against the
mother
[Music]
I wish I could I wish I can
give myself correct courage yeah you'd
be too busy but I see why they did it
yeah
well I understand why I just don't like
it
the tough dude out
you can't be engineering
what that is sick
hmm
and it's holding them there
hmm
okay
you cannot see really
what does that person do
[Music]
I guess I can send Kana over here
she wouldn't let me send it to the guys
right there on the corner
oh
[Music]
meet my tiger
[Music]
really
I keep forgetting here
[Music]
for Earth or
nope
um
second
quarter to two
you don't have one so
true than you think
[Music]
that is Elemental did something
uh let's go
so annoying
oh man
oh and we lost it
yeah I don't know
oh perfect just disconnected me a second
ago and yeah that was weird
all right
Tim can you pick yourself up
I'm down
let me sleep on that
you get knocked all the way out
can you pick yourself up or no
I gotta heal ya I will Vanquish you all
right
there's a fountain there's a fountain
there
it's a phone that's gonna pick you up
because then me I can fight my way we
can find our way to the phone you can
say it's up to you though how many
potions do you have a lot of potions
I have three but I'm not close enough
oh okay
you see the phone
why is the attic running from the beef
oh no
got it pull them towards you
can't just pick up
soon
and then about that life he wanted to
dip on me
he's like you and Malachi can handle all
that smoke by yourself
I don't understand what's going on
why would you not pick up
what are we doing what's going on
he's getting the major portal I guess
[Music]
what are you doing
what was that
why did you not pick up sin
I'm here for you friend
[Music]
that was the most ridiculous move I was
oh and he killed me thank you
don't fear any Folk
that's it for me
you got one right in front of you saying
I was trying to use the vortex to break
everything but
oh we got a attic as a Spearman next to
him we gotta get rid of that dude
[Music]
a bad guy or
oh okay that card
he's a bad guy
the goblin yeah
hmm
Unleashed nice
unleash pain
shot him yeah
he shot him with panic
nice
little Mystic ran up on Vodacom like
that
I know
[Music]
I'm so sorry sin I didn't even know that
you needed to be picked up until it's
too late
yeah I was like I don't know what he
doing right now
it was funny because I had one
I know he wasn't focused on him
[Music]
how's your how's your house who's low
uh
we're good now he's just down that's all
everybody's good he's dead yeah because
if I'll come pick me up and gave me
health
so because I could I could um also don't
use the phone yet save the fountain
unless you want to give out a full
health right and he'll wake up and feel
helpful he won't yeah he'll wake up if
he should wake up a while
I'll move over and get him if anything
okay all right so yeah we'll save it for
a little bit for the next turn
all right sins on you
pick you up
yeah slow
slow well I can get some of my health
back to my turn
um that's the fountain to Hillary we got
a lot of Thieves we got a lot of enemy
okay I can get Five Mile courage Within
oh you got some card or something
it should give me five I don't know I
think it'll give me three but it'll
still put me at six I would say save it
go ahead and hit it then it's fine yeah
yeah I don't want you to wasting it
where is that do you want me you know
what oh sorry Valentine's Day what
you're saying yeah technically here you
should be hunting them down
do you want me to drop one of my
hurricanes I have three of them that
would be nice because that area this
area here it is crazy right now it's
crazy over there so that's actually yeah
it's time
I love that move
's not good against bosses though that's
my only thing that's the strongest
bosses but adequate this to the end of
the attic went to the end of the turn
okay
all right so you guys want me just to
jump here like
go [ __ ] yeah
kill the kill the thing that's in right
next to you
what's that Leviathan do what is it
there's a bad dude right here
remember when I put the chains up and it
could no it's right there on the map
yes what does it do it just it holds
them they they they're locked to it they
can't leave oh they locked it
I think I could put that Leviathan on
that big bastard that keeps jumping yeah
yeah and you can keep them bending
where you going you ours now you belong
to us
oh the Leviathan is crazy it's like did
you think this is a game
that's dope that's dope so you can keep
enemies with the teleporting dude so
your man is meant for that dude you know
what I'm saying
disconnected
while we do that let me get my joy
plugged in because I'm at 20 when I just
in case you get hit
yeah so I think the next time you wait
for me
what's up is it is there any way for me
to mute myself
[Music]
I forgot I think I'm gonna come over
there where you are called
because I'm in danger over here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
he's over here okay
where is he
over here right over there
I got plans for him
up
[Music]
it doesn't look like that Leviathan goes
away until it's destroyed either
um
a very roughly caught up look it grabs
anyone that comes near it
oh that's beasty there are six dudes
attached to them I think I think
he got the big boy that stature that's
powerful
all right I'm gonna get the health cause
y'all hurting and look like what's
everybody's hell yeah
I need it
yeah all right what is money over here
let me work on it let me help you over
here I hope
unless y'all want me to take care of
this photo you want me to work with you
over here yeah just go ahead and uh
focus on those over there
there's one over here as well yeah let
me start working on it
[Music]
taste my Steel
taste my Steel
[Music]
how many cards do I get because I can
trace them into the bank to get a new
card
I got
anybody
six out of ten
that's cool how many cards you have
I'm fine don't go yet how many cars
all right I'm gonna give us all a card
oh leap
payment
got my solid recovery back nice what's
this thing gonna use it wisely
oh these things are so many right now
they said the blow yeah they said the
blow
that move is crazy oh
oh you gotta be not too much you're too
crazy
I'll get over there to help out
after you finish you get the summit and
the rest of them just can't
yes
good nice that was that was good so they
get scared when you smash the thing so
it's good to focus on the things
what's good when he does pretty much
anything
maybe just
and then we got to focus on all them
dudes tied to the Leviathan you know
we never did talk to that girl in the
middle of town square didn't we
nope nice what was that oh that was it
okay okay
that was the vortex
[Music]
you know the vortex there
Maybe
bravery
[Music]
um
more yeah I think I'm gonna stay right
where I'm at
okay
yeah
hold on can I do something else
um
I think that's
[Music]
uh
hurricane
well that's it
God
no
and they're stuck they can't move they
start that move is powerful and somehow
it's it's getting health
it gets more look at I'm trying to run
it it gets longer when they try to
channel honestly what's going on here
I gotta open up soon
thank you
what the hell
what the hell happened to you
oh damn
oh they got rid of it
they got rid of Kayla no they got rid of
my phone no
oh the Leviathan they busted delivered
yeah they spent all their they attacked
it
they got only resources on the back
I got another Leviathan
oh
save that for when your man come
come
cause I'm about to train them in get
another phone number oh [ __ ] I'm seven
of ten
years
we got a new car now
what's that howl of the Ancients what
the hell is that that you got It's like
a
it's one of those things that you can
use to uh
like weaken them
[Music]
okay
so anybody that's crazy oh we gotta get
over there to help out
the fos beeps mad before then
Connor's Dad yeah yeah but then I can do
that they can't Fleet
nice
[Music]
hmm
you need to start making them courageous
over there
[Music]
corruption I hope you can say yes
[Music]
take care Oh hailing boats
yeah I like the towns Folk
all right I'm not gonna make anybody
courageous this turn but I'm gonna do an
ability Blocker on this group of people
this tune will leave you speechless
now
none of them can do their special
abilities
kill the hurricane just hurt you
yep
that's new I've never seen that
oh we can attack it doesn't do as much
damage anymore
I think it's right here
oh
yeah it made their tax week that's good
for bosses
thought I wrote a boss
I think they're immune to that
could be a
um they're immune to everything
pretty much
all right y'all little dude's got
time can we get this dude out here
taste my steep
[Music]
we'll only go once
yo
that thing
I think it's like it makes you only go
once
I only got to go one two
I can teleport you over here
yeah I think I need that teleport
because I'm too far
all right let's get this one at up out
of here
nice
keep cat alive
[Music]
I thank the knots
but thank you you know when I go in
there the little dudes can follow us
[Music]
they're teleporter though
because they need to leave the board
after we beat not gonna mostly come to
me the exit is near me
foreign
[Music]
sting and scratch
foreign
[Music]
I got another I got another what you
call it
um
hurricane
big boy
these portals are heartless man
uh
oh I'm bugging I am not going to time
using my armor that's why I went I'm
only going once is your armoring up
stupid
[Music]
yeah armor up and jump to the party
they're gonna follow me but it's all
good
yeah but it kills travel time
yeah
I'll be right back I'm heading back
okay
okay
[Music]
all right let me see
we gotta take out we gotta trap this
thing quick
it's becoming like a serious issue
good and I want to know if we don't kill
them if we wanted to deal with him in
that last encounter that's my concern
you think we could kill this this coming
up turn
foreign
thing I can't see its health for some
reason
seven or seven
when's it teleporting there's a big boy
okay
yeah it doesn't have like maybe it just
got put down but it doesn't have the
timer yet
I feel like if I go over there I might
get killed though I only got four health
yeah you got to be careful
I would I would just focus on your man
get him
out of there
or
Doug is going to hit you then run
well I'm disconnected because his name
is Idle he'll be back
all right
everybody
foreign
[Music]
oh no one killed this dude
feel what do nope no um what's called
while a car was um going to but it's
been disconnected
foreign
targets
did I miss my turn
he's right here
yeah I missed my turn
are they coming through the portal now
where am I oh I'm up there
oh damn
he took a roar at least he didn't tickle
advice
oh my God he took a leviathan
oh damn
coming up Rob Lowe
so my question is
do you do you want me to use that song
Or resilience now
it's looking pretty pretty shady I'd do
anything you can you know
because that'll give us in a three by
three armor
we can't get a fight yet
let me get your car back get your chain
back wait hold on
I trust me
mm-hmm
[Music]
see if you can kill this guy he stole a
card
nice gotta go find them back
I didn't get my card back
oh no yeah you did really
here's a delay
yeah
[Music]
I wish I knew where that dude was I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go look for him
if we could stop him from running for
like two turns we could kill him
probably you know who would be good for
him to be assassinated
mm-hmm
[Music]
if you actually find them and put them
in a leviathan it'll be lit
that's the better yeah
oh okay
we're about to get cars
what the hell oh we gotta get rid of
this dude
telling me
Carl can kill him two hits
for Honor
oh got the the leap
nice what did I get
I got charged again okay
oh
the dude that got how many cards do you
have how to make
I got 10. okay no because I got I could
I think I could get the dude that got
your your card
yeah get him yeah unless you don't okay
make money because at the very least if
I don't want it anymore I could at least
just dump it
yeah get your car back
line up and down
[Music]
oh she's not over here anymore
[Music]
I'll get out of it I think he's over
here
where you think he's at yeah I think
he's like that direction yeah me too
yeah you should head over there you
gotta hunt them down
just wait till I find this dude man you
got the Leviathan chain them up lock him
up
nice got the key
what did you use those Vortex does
I want to know how you keep getting the
vortexes do you get one every game or
something a Vortex every time he kills
one of those smaller version and then
there's that big one yeah
the spit every time you kill the Elven
Spearman they look like they have them
they have the dust on them
that's what I noticed I kept getting
them because I was like why do I keep
getting all these
he was always close
yeah that could have went all the way
I would make
um attic courageous because he got we
need him to hunt that thing
but if he's away from you for a while I
mean after you do it after you kill or
do whatever you want to do yeah because
the moment I do that I'm going up here
I would have to move I would have to
move towards you guys yeah move towards
the money get the money and then give
what you call it yeah
[Music]
give it that give it the attic because I
got the armor
you're braver than you think
oh he said I'm bravery then I think
oh he's right there he's right here
right around the corner by that well
you got to get them we're going to
ignore the summoning riffs and get him
he is right here
he is two squares behind
oh
he's two squares behind this wrist right
here
oh they roughing up the cell sword
yo they merging in the big arrests you
see that
yo how much health does that have it's
getting stronger 15.
that means gonna something something
crazy yeah just kill that kill that call
don't worry about it kill this thing
right here
okay I need to focus on it this thing is
gonna summon something serious
[Music]
oh there's a potion thing over there did
he teleport
is he over here
no he's right here oh we barely cannot
see him okay I know what I'm gonna do I
know what I'm gonna do
we need a line of sight
eventually
[Music]
and then eat what I need from you about
her is when you get to me is to
Courageous my behemoth
there you go Leviathan
leviath in him now
too heavy
[Music]
for him
oh
he won't let us live
I'm very disappointed right now
yeah
that seemed like the perfect thing to do
is leviath in here
I appreciate you Aaron Johnson yeah we
we tried to give you content
oh cause you got the keys he out
try to run on us so get some gold first
get all that gold first
but he got two people that's serious in
front of him we gotta fight sting yeah
you're right
that's a lot of gold though no he had it
he has to kill him
yeah you can't leave without it anyway
cool thing you got at least kind of why
I said maybe y'all should jump over here
we start lingering until we get out
I'm just worried about this Summoner bro
like we're gonna have to deal with him
I don't know how dimeo do like that I
think if we don't kill him
he gonna terrorize us probably during
the Boston counter yeah and the boss is
probably going to be rough enough the
boss is gonna be crazy you know how they
do with the double bosses
[Music]
all right
if you could come to me
I would say just put my Behemoth I would
say hit that right hit that hit that
spot that's what and then um actually
see if you kill it see if you kill it
forget me crazy if you could kill it
that'd be great
you're gonna have to use both of your
head the most I can do
the most I can do is four
right well I'm not gonna kill it just
just braver than you think yeah but let
the things stay alive from here well it
sounds so okay yes come on guys
let's go what will the themes do
oh they're about to kill our homeboys
they better kill the homies well he's
been kind of useless so oh wow
he did
you surprised the thing didn't run
oh
that's what we get
oh yeah they got citizen for running
[Music]
they say yeah you wanted to be out you
want to leave your team
[Music]
hold on I got something I think that can
help us I don't know if how's
everybody's house doing low low low
how's everybody doing I'm at nine all
right now I'm at four
I'm at four I got I got I got something
to heal the whole team right now yeah I
do it
um because it'll get sent up
well we hope so it should it was
everyone it should that was rich
yup he's um all right cool everyone hit
that bastard hit the main dude I don't
even care anymore if we go down he's
coming with us
I can't because he's he's protected by
that screen
oh I can't hit him can you charge him I
literally can't
I would have to waste to turn I have
only one turn right now what I would do
in front of him
I can hit this hit him hit the thing all
right this barrier is for is for the
rift
mm-hmm
it just prints I mean it only deflects
it only deflects projectiles and spells
yeah I can physically hit him but I
still but right now there's a little
baby one in front of him that I can't
make it just kill the big kill the big
thing kill that first okay
last thing we need is I think
teleporting something else
giving us something else
killed it kill the screen yeah you
killed yeah killed the teleporter how
much I hope they got I'm not seeing it
it should have five right here
unless they got Health back it should
have five
now you're gonna have to hit what you
call it hit that the boss I mean it's a
mess
when I hit or whatever your most
strongest [ __ ] is as long as it's not
Magic
because it may like you good yeah I
don't think there's anything about him
that's Magic
it's delicious
nice oh you weakened though
yeah
but better than nothing
all your hits gonna do the way last
season now I wish I was able to get in
there now he gonna run
should I go for the potions or should I
hit them once
Adam I feel like I'm weakened I'm not
gonna do a whole lot
better than nothing except my way
35 or 48.
it's gonna keep tripping
we have to get rid of this dude I'm
telling you we don't get ready to do we
go to the third level and this dude
ain't dead he's gonna keep coming back
with full health it's gonna be a problem
use your most powerful whatever follicle
whatever is you got one of them
hurricanes use it use your powerful [ __ ]
now
I bet you you can't move why this
barrier's up
yeah because I think that would be him
being cheap I don't know ever since I
put up that can you withstand things
and he hasn't moved yeah he hasn't moved
good [ __ ] I don't see a chain going on
him
I don't see a chain one but I remember I
don't think it's attached to him because
when I saw you put it it said too heavy
next to him
so he a little bit over the weight limit
for the
accordingly we got the soil recovery we
got the behemoth
nice whatever that was we like it
only did one to him but hey better than
nothing did for me
nice level three I thought I'm about to
level up the level three
Super Saiyan that'll be good for you on
that part
yes let's go come on oh she's so close
to something
hard time
I'm gonna tag you something on Facebook
they call it they found a giant like a
giant bald eagle in Texas that thing's
massive
man yeah what you call it you know damn
it
where'd he go where'd he go he hit him
too he's right here he's over here
whatever this is what the hell just
happened
something came up from behind me and hit
me
I wonder Spearman
oh
he's doing eight
yeah he hurt me
uh it's time to be smart cannot be
broken
[Music]
right now let's get in the mix
[Music]
come on
your ballista hasn't hit anything
it hit something from behind it hit
somebody out so bad it hit somebody's
head I was like why
so mad at that
oh I know you didn't want that you
wanted to get over there yeah I meant to
grab the other one
um I do what you try to do
[Music]
you won't escape this
it's too heavy too
oh you trying to put it on him yeah I
was trying to see if I could stop him
from falling as to fight the other dude
nice that's cool Super Saiyan kinda it's
time to go sand transform get gold oh
that's right she level two he was only
level one no he's like damn not bad
level two already she's level three
foreign
[Music]
if I remember correctly she could
temporarily go level four can't she
three is the temporary level and then um
yeah but it's crazy
[Music]
yeah I want to do that
confused oh my God yes
that was good that was good come on
Elemental let's go come on why are you
shooting things I don't care
which means there you go kill me it's
kind of crazy that song of hurricane
with the Leviathan because
if they tied up and they just did the
hurricane said to them but they sending
mad people over the city they said an
Express train over the city
oh
oh he healed
oh can this Carly took that for you
don't worry about me I can pick myself
up
okay I'll get you a door
are you good you gonna pick this up you
good yeah
kill that silence next to you
kill him yeah you you could kill
okay I was gonna go with you to go I
thought Volcan was good because he could
pick himself up he got the Leviathan
there he got a friendly there he got my
Behemoth yeah yeah that's right yeah
let's finish this let's get this tool he
got to go
I'll go as far as I can go
open that door let's see him if you got
the Panic dust see we
uh he definitely in there she didn't get
the chance no I already used that was
two yeah my fault
all right everyone got Max I'm getting
rid of these Hal agents we don't need a
weekend
yeah I'm doing it one more time
barbaric Shane would you drink change
another Behemoth yes
you sure
got the health back that's crazy
and cause Havoc
I like that
hopefully he hits Connor and not you
yeah you need kind of protection
[Music]
it's my turn calm down that's right
yeah pick this up
anything powerful or hit him
I wonder if I can grab one of you and
yank you to me
probably I don't know we should test it
I mean I wouldn't test it now but we
definitely need to test that that's a
good thing since
[Music]
you know oh yes come on let's go
whatever that you're about to do
okay whatever you're down to three
and
hit him yeah come on tough part get
gangster
get gangster kill him
I'm trying to stay right where I'm at oh
no I don't know
yeah
and then he tied up he tied up and he
got shot yeah you're tied up and shot
up to eight people
nice we gonna get you bro
he was picked up by two he was hooked by
two different leviathans yup I saw that
he was tied to two levises oh
who did he hit
Connor he hit Connor
gotta get this dude
please thank you
no oh no no I can't I'm not on his turn
wait hold on
I could watch it Dustin
I was gonna hit you oh just take both
turns and hit him
wait it's free hold on
we'll go
yeah you can hit diagonal
what do you want to get his fat ass
yeah you're tired of him
hit this one nope hit it no thank you
big money no wings no wins oh
that's right oh that's a lot okay I
don't care about them we gonna jump this
boy jump him some awful 2020. let's get
him all right attic
him up whatever oh yes let's go let's go
too heavy too whatever that was too
heavy but I don't care still did seven
thirty down to 13. let's go
rough him up
let's go
whatever that was you did too
let's go let's go get him jump him and
let them leave time up oh he's so close
he's gonna run like a little [ __ ]
[Music]
we need to tie up mechanic with this
dude
from one point to another
Joseph that is dirty I feel that he said
yeah it was some surprise
you see yeah what's up I heard you was
outside
this is stupid you said yeah oh block I
heard you were all blocked by yourself
what's good
get away
that was a good shot though be breaking
the whole block over here though I won't
put up my email down was it was there
anybody where you were asking
um yeah the the boss with the key
all right got the money grab the money
head towards us
can you oh yeah hey wait can you grab a
potion
in the potion I can only grab I can only
grab one over there
what do you want what do you want for
the potion
luck magic I don't even need Magic
I got Global from vulnerability
that's good oh invisibility
oh I'm out let it be if if they don't
down me this turn I am going to drink
the hell is
I hate him
I hate him
yeah
he couldn't have went further away
he went to the other side of the map bro
he is yeah he's right here he's all the
way here we got to get him in I don't
care I ain't leaving until I feel this
man
oh scorpions they came in my arms
for you
how y'all doing on cards I have four
I have nine eleven
all right because I can give her I give
everybody a card right now okay
let's do that
oh the stupid screen man
it's good
maybe we can portal to him again I got
the portal you got another portal all
right good good oh you want me to win
like that [ __ ] happens yeah you good for
him you good I go we thought we needed
the Archer but actually the auction
would not have helped dealing with this
he's over here
hold on I gotta armor up I am [ __ ]
he's over here
with over here
we got an element so we got a range let
me start working on a minute
I mean since you got the the sunshine
I think we need to kill this dude first
and get the key
yeah I'm far though
I'm not gonna be able to I'm not gonna
be able to get time in time just hit the
regulars then hit the ones that are
close to you
yeah there's this yeah these dudes here
yeah yeah all right let me work on them
you can oh man they got some strong
units over there
yeah they strong I will tell you all
right
[Music]
I wonder also lock gives you probably
better dice rolls more crits when I live
I've never seen a luck potion yeah
neither have I
[Music]
oh you only got one Health
yeah I'm trying to figure out what's
best for me
because you guys are going to boat next
turn so I'm trying to be around for that
I can't see what's up here
this might be a health shrine
let me yeah it might be
we haven't seen a fountain yet no we
didn't see one phone on earlier okay yep
we saw one
[Music]
and we used it
yep
there should be at least one more
[Music]
yes see good risk good risk
we know what to do next to her
[Music]
Magic
this okay
all right
first things first
oh
you're going invisible okay oh yeah
all right you want me to start
collecting gold
yes
basically you're the Assassin right now
oh I can't make it
that's all right if I if I attack that's
going to break my stuff right most
likely
a funny looking invisibility
monster time
oh yo
thanks
yo he walked through me and got poisoned
yeah you got a fax looks like that a
visibility drug got effects
and oh they killed they killed
yeah
get down me too
don't keep fighting when it's my turn
I'm going to get that health potion
that Health thing it'll get them up
okay okay
because he goes after me so he'll still
get a go this time
unfortunately
almost up straight line speed
[Music]
yup I didn't want
it
uh that was a mistake come on
but you're gonna get the poacher so I
don't even matter God damn it sucked
all right oh this is a fantastic turn
hey at least you still hit one
should have opened up
can you hurt one of them
or at least hit the elemental will blow
up if you kill it but only got eight
oh what the hell
okay
what was that
I like I don't know I've never done it
that's why I did it
oh
you don't remember what the name of it
was it was a barbarian chain or
something like that I just I didn't know
what it did I thought I would be able to
like grab someone and throw in them but
it wouldn't
okay
[Music]
all right sin it's your turn
so you get pushed
I'm no longer
I didn't help us
[Music]
did it go through the portal it went
through the pool it went through the
portal whatever you did went into the
portal Unleashed
yes we got the key back
no no no
star was good that was still good
oh my God this hell the Ancients man
it's good but I just don't need it right
now
what does it do
it's the one that weakens them
how many do you have with them two
he's out in the open
these are the streets yeah he's right
here
what Mark him again
yeah I see him
I'll never get to it one time though I'm
sure it's good oh they they form
devastated and things yo
Devastator
hit the voice yeah probably break it
oh you didn't avoiding yeah it takes
dust as well so if you don't want to do
it I'll do it I don't have Vortex dust
so I'm not doing that yeah
no don't hit it don't hit it
some shot with divorce
the noise I wanna shot my fault that's
fine
if they gotta hit it anyway I didn't hit
him anyway
go see if you can get this chest
I can't do it on this term but can you
get rid of this ice and a mental next to
me before he puts me down
oh
he gonna blow up oh damn I got no armor
this is a complete messed up turn
sorry
um
thank you
bye now
nice oh so those that's what those do
okay they're looking I did not know
those that they did all that
I know
why I said my my turn was skip
because
Frozen Frozen
skips and turn
[Music]
well I'm invisible it's a good one it's
a good thing I use my dust on my turn
oh he's got
he's got one HP left
just get me something useful
what did he want to trade with options
80 card any card in my hand
and he'll give us what
[Music]
um I don't know
the card to the beggar
yeah give me some waxy whatever no
it's not something an old man like me he
just took the car today did he take the
card no
okay so you don't like that
no we still got the option to give up
how's the beggar gonna beg for a
difference
um I don't wanna I don't want to give
him I don't want to give him my song a
recovery no we definitely not getting a
minute
I have two songs of resilience
no
he just ain't getting nothing until we
get over there
I'm just gonna close this yeah
right
no you don't have Gucci what
how many times they went out
uh next turn I think I'm gonna start
attacking this thing
I'm gonna start heading over
[Music]
yeah one more turn before before it uh
I'm at 13. I'm gonna say screw it I'm
gonna attack this this portal here
[Music]
the monsters are moving
are you still invisible yeah that's
different
yeah if I'd have known that all kind of
yeah oh my God I have 1290 coins
and now I'm gonna arm her up finally
[Music]
I'm surprised that we've lived this long
yeah we were still considering and we've
had a few misplays we've killed this
dude like five times like this dude
spawns like five times
[Music]
[Music]
so what if we kill him and he's still at
the boss
what are we gonna learn now
[Music]
I'd rather learn this than learn the
other way
he come back with 49 Health we didn't
kill him and then we fight him and the
boss
what oh
with that three
I'm not to say you're being bold with
that three
like what's the worst that can happen I
die
I don't know now you can kill him but
he's gonna blow up
foreign
happen he's throwing them from right
here
[Music]
they coming for the boys
we gotta kill that thing man
yeah
um
I'm gonna start if I kill that an
element is going to blow up don't worry
about that
don't hit because you're going to kill
somebody get the card yeah I'm gonna go
get the card honestly I don't know
there's nothing if I hit him there's
gonna be a problem for y'all
[Music]
all right I'm gonna give you guys
another card
don't don't wait wait wait
um
so get rid of one of your cards now E
before he does that all right get rid of
a white card now
it's gonna give me another card
yeah but at least you wouldn't have been
full
now
oh my fault that's okay I got rid of the
car to give it back to me
okay
you thought she was getting away Bandit
well now I'm gonna go down anyway
because he's gonna come for me
but you can you can move can't you
[Music]
you need to back up let Connor
yeah the con yeah that's what you didn't
know
I'm gonna have to kill that [ __ ]
Elemental
fly
on that
I think he wanted to make sure it died
Unleash Your Right Todd is still gonna
get yeah I'm gonna do that yeah I was
gonna do that from the beginning
oh oh my God oh my God
Jesus oh no do the trick
see you later come back room 88 86 53
see you tonight see you in a minute
[Music]
I don't think you can do that anymore
here it comes because now you come back
as the same character remember
[Music]
so we got to beat the board there so he
could come back yeah
[Music]
he's in he's just dead
really yeah he's dead
no he's right here
wait wait where's he point him out
where's he at
right here oh yeah okay good
[Music]
I say we run
after we kill that dude
oh I'm about to say run now that one
hell that we came this for yeah you're
right what we should do
um while icon get next to us if you have
one of your solar recoveries we're gonna
need it now
I think he's here somewhere because he
would sin would see him if he was up
there
yeah excited to be able to kill him too
recoveries
yep yeah get get close to us let's form
Devastator and then yeah we'll we'll
start a recovery all of us after you
handle your business or whatever
he's over here somewhere soon
foreign
[Music]
over here somewhere yeah Sam can get it
all still got to do is just move the
farthest to this direction over there
and then see him
but Connor's level one again
guessing
all this fall this as you can so you get
a lot of sight
they step away
it might have
yeah he's calling what is he calling me
he's good
yeah
they not let you in
what they doing
you can't move the screen
what about doing a a cancer work a
complete um closed emails
tacos demio and then relaunch and then
jump in
don't worry about it at this point of it
all right cool
[Music]
this [ __ ] they should sit there
oh what happened who got a magic potion
you got stuck
this guy stole a car from someone
stole the car from Hope on us addict
never mind
so who got a someone's got the magic
potion stolen that was what happened no
attic got his something back I think
oh
man there's so much beef
all right well let me hit this dude
all right now
no they let you
know yeah now I can move around I
couldn't do anything before uh cool I
thought that was some new cheat
prevention
[Music]
but I did lose all my cash all my cash
is gone okay
I'm frozen I can't do anything now well
when what you're gonna get right next to
us um yeah
you gotta get right next to us so that
on it on his turn oh you're gonna go
towards him because I want you to have
that song of recovery so you can keep
slowly healing that he gives you I'd
rather you just get to us
and just like hit this or something and
then get back to us
or this abandoned here there's beef over
here the handle
[Music]
as we get the song we all need that song
of recovery
once we had that then we can go chase
and hunt down and we'll be good
foreign
you
see if you can line right here yep yep
come on I need this hit I need this hit
come on don't miss us there we go
all right cool
yeah she stuck my scroll
killer um the summoning thing and then
come back to the same spot
[Music]
who me
yeah yeah kill the summoning thing and
then come back to the same spot
I was gonna go after that what's his
name
we need this listening we need that song
recovery Oh I thought we already did it
I ain't gonna
no no
it hasn't been Valentine's time yet
you could pull that thing towards you
you pulled up the barrel the rift
I don't think you can
yeah he's done it before
foreign
can I be right here and you guys still
reach me
nope no you have to be right on us
is that portable I mean
[Music]
you're about looking because if you yeah
oh okay
yeah he actually needs that that's
actually smart
I don't need magic you could just skip
yeah skip your turn if you want and
while I can't get between us on his turn
and then give us the soil recovery
and we did that I don't even I don't
even need to move
nice
recovered perfect and that's going to
keep giving us two help over time that's
what I want and now on your next turn go
chase go hunt yeah I'm smart ass you
make them courageous you gonna be
healing that's what I want as you chase
them down and you'll be good
and I'll send us his turn
so weak now I lost my own and everything
everything it is so weak
if you can just try to move
as far as you can because it's like we
gotta see where he's at
I know Australia
okay nice
where the hell have you been
I don't know you're welcome to what the
hell
yo
no we got corruption on the stage
get rid of that ASAP
that's crazy what was that was that
amazing yes
foreign
[Music]
over there too
does anyone know where this dude is
the last time I saw him shoot something
was over in this direction
over where
I'll give you a call I gave y'all a card
okay yeah oh this way yeah
you got to go get him
[Music]
he's probably like over here something
hopefully you can see him
close
foreign
do you want me to do you want me to
Courageous you would then attack the guy
or you want me to just attack the guy
which got a dog or the big or a
reptilian which is what are you talking
about The Bard I mean um the thug this
guy
um
do you have any one of the do you have a
hurricane
I do
I would put the hurricane over here
and then attack the attack the Brew it
won't protect it oh okay
I can put it
I can put it on
I could put it as far as here
it's up to you whatever you want to do
[Music]
you know your powers
it's just a little tornado
and I'm gonna courageous you so you take
less damage boy look actually no
kill the dog
um how much health he has yes you kill
him
then next turn I'll usually get your
courageous
guess what slow-mo's playing Halo
infinite now
who is
Oh okay that's cool
he's playing the new pit man
[Music]
I think he's here now what would change
where
I think he's like here yeah
oh he right next to me this little dude
what I think is generating slimes oh yo
when they get too big oh my look look at
the enemies is spawning on us
oh you can't let that you got to take
that King get us out of here the moment
I kill him you got to be right there
forever yeah in a moment yeah
uh I don't know where he is either
you're gonna get him he has to be
somewhere over here
he's either here or in here
like this hair
somewhere in this General vicinity
he's got to be
preserved
[Music]
I already used that in health already no
I just need a fuse over there yeah he's
got to be over here somewhere
so he's over here then
I hope
[Music]
it's my turn okay my bad
get rid of that wrist bro it's going to
turn it's gonna right in front of you
it's gonna summon yeah
these Rifts when they when they get to
level three version oh boy
it was a crazy
let's Dodge this
courage is what will save us
thank you
you're
laughing
this will cause some egg
somebody saying losers
I like to know where this dude is
me too he gonna probably start snitching
now
oh that slime hit me from there
no he didn't finish
yes Miss he comfortable hiding yeah he
might be over here
what do you think yeah
all right or he could be over here sit
in the spawn do you do you want me to
look or do you want me to go over here
and I'll go over here
okay I'm trying to box him in
let's get away from that slime if you
want me to go you want me to go up or
you want me to go here
please be here
[Music]
bro this is crazy
[Music]
he's got to be here
we're up here
we've checked everywhere else
yeah he's got to be over here in this in
the spot he's got to be with on the end
in the corner yeah in the spawn
he's very correct I love it
yeah so he's got to be near where
centers at yeah he's got to be down here
he's got to be yeah he's got to be over
there
he's stuck up up here
but it's he put these portals down here
he usually tries to put portals away
from him
he usually doesn't put Wars like right
next to him you know what I'm saying yep
I agree
foreign
oh no
yeah
that thing keeps summoning big creatures
over and over again yeah
we gotta find it which way y'all want me
to go over here go over here yeah I'll
go that way
[Music]
all right this little back in here
Sinister was just over here citizen was
just over there
was something go this way it doesn't
matter he could teleport at any turn he
could have teleported their last yeah
it usually shows him when he teleports
it shows when he's visible teleporting
if he's a visible and he teleports it
doesn't show it
and once he crosses well
I would go here and let sin go here
[Music]
okay sure
just get in this hallway here and I
think
that's all that's all you need to do
so I knew it was dead before
[Music]
get the gold addict
oh it's my turn
[Music]
[Music]
this is the only other place I believe
he could be
this is ridiculous I I do feel like this
is too unbalanced like like there's
nothing we could do get glitched out I
think it glitched out a little bit with
the disconnects and stuff because it
wasn't he wasn't behaving like that
we would always see where he went every
single time
and then he would start showing when he
was off screen invisible he would start
he hasn't been even spawning teleports
anymore
maybe he only spawns teleports when you
destroy the ones he currently has we
just been letting them just run wildly
letting them rock yeah that's true too
time to level the playing field
destroy one now so he should be showing
himself
we have been letting a little while but
let's say yeah good morning
[Applause]
I'm looking
I'm looking at the whole map all right
something open here
but he doesn't need doors so that's not
him
he's not there he ain't there he's got
to be over here
that's the only last one unless he's
teleported and the time we've looked in
these rooms for him
I guess
maybe he runs after you do enough damage
to him
[Music]
he was on that map too
he was on that map
I'm gonna start and y'all let y'all
Chase I've been attacked since I got the
key I'm gonna start heading back
[Music]
I'm looking for him I just don't see him
yeah I'm just gonna start heading
towards the exit I have the key
foreign
there's a chance he runs after he does
some of damage
could be maybe some yeah but you know
this sucks we had him in one he's gonna
see him what happens if he died from
poison or something we just don't know
wouldn't we have heard him
he would have heard him and he used to
get the points thing on screen
strike
they're using Cana
This Will Call some ache
yes it's definitely
all right I'm gonna head towards the
exit
because all right then see if you could
find him over here right before we leave
in these two rooms and if you don't find
them Cog will just get us out
yep you know we did everything we can to
search for this dude this dude don't
want to be found
I'm scared to go over here because I
feel like I'll get hit by all those big
things
I wouldn't go over there yeah yeah
that's a good idea
I agree just head back this way
I will
I agree the last time like I said when
everything was knocking normal he was in
this area I don't know how this man
completely he'd never moved we've never
seen him teleport
all of a sudden he go he gone
[Music]
nice
just gonna cash out
let's just hope that we we can get uh
you get over here before uh
more people
oh run
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh yeah oh okay gangster all right guys
just accept your fate
my gangster okay okay all right it's up
okay listen to go take the bullet
how'd that not take any damage
she ain't about to get him done oh nice
you lucky nice
[Music]
he did a shimmy
them out
I'm gonna check this area right here
before we leave
[Music]
because this should take you two turns
to get there
[Music]
um
so I'm using
I know
listen uh he's one for that chest
oh God there's so much beef over there
though
what the hell is that
oh y'all want me to go this way or you
want me to go the direct way
go whatever way gets you there quicker
the quickest
[Music]
see if this dude's here
foreign
like this until all the disconnects all
the things I think it is good job said
if you can reach that um
what is that thing Gorgon
yep oh those are mad tough and they got
armor those are mad oh [ __ ] isn't a
problem yeah single oh I see just gonna
get the chest and then as soon again
you'll help me I'm gonna get him out of
there I know what they're doing you're
like all I got to do is touch the chest
I know
yeah
I got Katie I got Katie
look at me trying to chase him crazy is
that right you got kid we'll get you out
of there we'll get you out of here
the only thing is
nah I'm good at least yeah
just leave yeah let's leave
way out okay
[Music]
I have 1500 gold
I got 1470. all right let me um
1753 I don't have this wait hold on I
don't have saving leaves so someone else
is the host it's me so somebody all
right same and then uh text me the code
I'm not gonna do anything until you say
we'll leave it in uh text me the card
and I'll text up the code
because we cannot lose this safe let's
say it was too important
foreign
[Music]
foreign
is there any more string potions for you
to buy be
this potions
they got behemoths they got okay
oh Rejuvenation that's too important I
need that
thank you kindly
well chosen
all purchases of final I
have more gold for my covers thank you
very much
[Music]
I got so much money yeah I've really
listened and spent all the money I have
oh I got everything oh I gotta buy this
invincible
I gotta sell actually some medium tier
cards to get a class tier cards
yeah
I wish I could still go
I spent all of my money
it is it is impossible it is impossible
for me to spend all my money
all right that's okay so you gotta just
take the best car so whatever's the
medium to that's probably the same part
as me
same boat
here soon
so
the only card I picked up
a card I picked up two cards that gives
me an extra action
I picked up song of recovery
I got three healing Wards two behemoths
Rejuvenation invincibility two posts I'm
ready
I got I got rid of offense card just for
the team like we gonna survive
that's the time
I can I can get I can either
buy one card
or I can or I can get rid of my
hurricane
oh and pick up how many hurricanes do
you have
one
what are the two cars that you would get
rid of the hurricane for
teleportation
yeah
uh Scroll of lightning
do you have do you have how many of the
ones that song recoveries and the um the
one that gave song resilience how many
of those do you have we'd eat those I I
just I just bought a song of recovery
okay it was the first one I bought
um
and I have two from the previous
dungeon yeah I have two songs of
resilience
and then okay
so I can either get rid of the hurricane
or pick up one of the two
if you get rid of the hurricane what's
the two that you can pick up
well I could pick up any one of these
but
because I have what are these
I got him him of obstruction which
um negates all the abilities special
abilities
ain't gonna work on both I have the
piercing voice which um able to it does
two or four points of damage to all the
enemies in a ten by one
all right what else
there's another hurricane
[Music]
oh you already got one good I know what
was the other option
the other ones are zero so
zero cost so there's three health
potions
a panic powder a web bomb and flask of
water
so you would and a rid of okay
and the uh Gas Lamp how many health
potions do we have currently
one
so basically I could trade in
you know I mean I could pick up one
health potion but that'd be it for me
if you pick up one hell potion now you'd
still be able to keep this song I mean
the the lightning I mean the tornado
yeah
I would do I could pick up one cart I
can pick up one card now right yeah
keep the tornado you got two reasons how
to get rid of yeah the only way I would
yes our only way I would get rid of the
tornado is if there was a song a
recovery or a song of resilience
available to be bought that's the only
way that you could sacrifice tomato for
that but other than that keep the
tornado just buy another health potion
and be balanced
all right
and then before we start let me just
take a leap
yeah I'm I'm already up
uh let me
can't wait to see what this boss is oh
my God
I'm just gonna move yo this cat is
sitting on the throne
yo oh boy
look who we got in the corners look at
everybody in the corner he got them on
display
I know that's crazy look at his throw
worlds huh we a Sabbath old throw World
old old ass crack attack
crazy
oh that's insane
[Music]
your face was all image
I'll try to get there's a rule about you
yo look at this yo he has I like what
you can see
he has 138 hit points
this is wow
the fact that you could see him like
this put his piece down for a second
because I'm trying to take a photo it
shows you yeah thank you
you see the arrow in his chest
no let me see
he got wet yeah he been killed before he
came back that's crazy that's ill
[Music]
and then
all right let me over up though
all right I'm gonna peek and see
so I am now hold on should I do the
follow resilience and give us all armor
yeah
yeah we definitely gonna need that just
move back just move back I already moved
twice because I arm it up on my first
time
I'll be back oh wait y'all let me know
how it goes
oh they're mad dudes next to us
[Music]
so I'm wrong if we stay here I can armor
everybody up
because B already has armor
[Music]
all right man there's a lot of people
over there
yep
some serious beef going on
uh where's my dude
oh he's right there
foreign
oh no
[Music]
oh Tina's not here
I wanted to hit her too
[Music]
well she was she dead last turn like
when in the other sin
on the other level was she dead
yeah I think she just died
[Music]
do you want me to wait for her or just
go ahead and just armor us up
yeah let's just get moving
all right
let the music embrace you my friends
[Music]
courage is what will save us
ah it's a potion for Speed
[Music]
fiends reveal
foreign
[Music]
yo yo what up what is it why does it do
that bro like it's so crazy it's plugged
in
it's like why is it disconnecting and I
don't have no Auto sleeping
[Music]
I'm doing these horrificing Regal bursts
yo yo yo
what is this
what the hell
what is he doing
he's pretty much making a maze but we
can't get to him wait wait is is he
doing what he has hands like we do
yeah so I'm gonna assume those crystals
ain't good
and whatever he's about to smash on that
Crystal cannot be good
so I think we should go back and focus
on the crystal how much health does the
48.
damn
yo
they do one damage have three movement
they're immune to stun charm ability
blockers weak in panic Tangled confused
blinded Frozen friendly you did say a
recovery by yourself and not with the
team
I didn't do summer recovery
online joint I mean you got solar
resilience by yourself
no it's me it's Sinister it's the Soviet
all right so so did y'all all have how
come what you call a Game Addict don't
have oh songs
he moved
out of my zone I've never do song and
resilience without the hope I can't
leave y'all without doing y'all teamwork
[Music]
we need teamwork addict we cannot do
moves like that no no one says no no one
talks at the very beginning
he said it when when it was cognito's
turn incognito said he he really you
cannot we have to listen to each other
y'all all this solo Mission stuff is not
gonna work hero ball is not gonna work
I'm telling y'all right now that was a
waste just then complete waste
oh
that's gonna be two
oh
I can do it
that's okay
no I'm just interested that I can find
out how to use that that's going to be
really helpful
no he had he had to learn Florida The
Vortex another vortex
you ain't got Canada
no oh God this is not a good start she
died when you when you left remember she
died protecting me right right right
right you're right I forgot I forgot
I thought they would get my back when it
started to turn
your man got these dudes on display the
hardest dudes we fought it's like
display
you know they're going to come down
eventually
yeah oh God the spider this is crazy
how do you even get to him hold on
you can't physically get to them because
the steps are closed
look you can't even these steps unless
you these get busted and then these can
go up
I think when you kill these one of those
things come down yeah
he's a millionaired rift beam Regal
burst the grand Rapture and King's Bash
so you want you want me to hit this
thing yeah I don't trust them things he
got his hand over there he's ready to
smash it just don't look good
oh no oh yeah
okay at least he didn't have to go
hit this thing hard
come come
Unleash Your rap
oh my God the thing has so much health
oh my God
it just made me Frozen and it held and
it healed itself
oh oh my God the hell was that oh he's
moving it like a chess piece he's moving
it like a chess piece
oh those are the so yeah oh
all right time for the heal Awards
it's time for the Healer Awards I got
y'all yo this dude is moving
characters like we he playing demio he
played
[Music]
um
with VR
[Music]
probably I would say all four of us jump
one
yeah yeah and then worry about it I feel
like I feel like we gotta split because
he he just he focuses on those and I
feel like if we stay on one he's gonna
hit all four of us over and over again
I got the healing words for that don't
worry bro I got you okay if we get all
four together yeah I'll tell you I got
you let me go get sin
because he's healing stuff and if we
split off we're not gonna have enough
DPS I don't think
yeah break the wall down and get to the
thing if you can
hold eyes oh you jumped over the old
junk oh he built for this they usually
make the new character have a power
that's built for that built for the
encounter
that was crazy he can move it up though
it's cool
I bet you that Leviathan will stop it
from moving
yes you you you're built for this
encounter the way the way what you call
it is built for the last encounter
you're built for this killer
I think once he is not able to move he's
gonna let down one of those uh yeah
what are some bosses he gonna let the
homies there yeah I really like his
sleep how he's got ghosts
we got to give it up to resolution guys
this is the fourth Boston kind of now
with excellent mechanics you already
know this gonna be fine we scared
because we know what's about to happen
yeah
oh damn I'm full damn
you're gonna ask me
you can't I don't think you can get you
guys
oh y'all all low
is everybody low no I was hitting the
wall to get to him
what the oh
oh yeah he's on the field
yo he's on the field
oh
no he didn't saw it yo B is down
Guardian is down
[Applause]
that's crazy
you put the snitch eye on him
well all right
is like I don't know what to do
he's smart do what you do
sing the song of dust
I got it so so I got disconnected I got
a Laval uh I got a a leviathan do you
think I should try to
uh sell both of those
maybe if he can't pick them up yeah
he'll be lucky yeah he can't move him I
think your Leviathan will work on those
I don't like how he is in my face like
that
foreign
pick up what you call it I can pick
myself up and then
I can pick myself up too
I can pick both of them up
all right to do that then do that do it
do it
and then I'm gonna get a healing once I
get myself up I'll make a healing Ward
over there you have more to give do you
have multiple healing words
yes I got I got three I'm ready to go I
might drop off the whole sport
yep I'm gonna drop one I'm gonna drop
like one here like in the you know in
the area because when they move I'll
drop one here and like one here yeah yep
yep that's what I'm doing I'm gonna move
as soon as I get up
one more turn all right one more time
I know you had that
yeah
all right let's see if I can do this
don't pick up the chest because I'm full
oh okay
do not pick up the chest pick me up
yep well I'm trying I'm trying to do
this strategically this is about the end
for you
I'm trying not to be in the dirt yeah he
start doing his zigzag
and
the music is crazy
yeah
see if you can hit this thing
all right yeah if you can get rid of
that I can put the Leviathan right where
that is yes
yep smart there we go teamwork brothers
that's what I need to hear working
together well how much else does I have
it's got four
oh you [ __ ] serious I took it down
that corner wall doesn't it
[ __ ]
oh I'm oh let me try something slick I
want to see if this works
I tried hitting again and then oh it
works it worked
okay I'm coming guys oh do I need that I
need an armor up I can't I can't do
everything on this turn I'm sorry that's
okay I tried I tried hitting this but it
didn't work next time I'll try I can't
do it if I don't armor up I gotta
respect this dude Gangsta
if you could break the wall and maybe
put the Leviathan or what was your plan
I was gonna see the Leviathan can't grab
it because of this do you think I should
wait a turn
until we destroy this first
break the wall and then oh God I see
what you're saying I see what you're
saying
we all get a card
resilience
Gain Is Back
I'm getting over here
I need to be a part of that
I'm okay to do something fresh
[Music]
that small
okay I cannot use
The Vortex card on his hands
so his hands are considered bosses
really Royal silence yeah
wait don't I don't know if you want to
pick up chests
it won't let me
click on the hands either so
we got to kill those hands yeah we got
to kill those hands let's all focus on
that left one
mm-hmm
all right
deep thought
oh this thing's about to mess up I have
nothing I have nothing as soon as I get
over here I got y'all as soon as I just
gotta get over there I had to armor up
first
yeah it's pointless coming over here
yeah like I was doing extra magic damage
teleport to us
are you trying to molest me y'all
smack the dog
we got we got the we got the thing the
thing goes down again he's dead
dude
what does it do
do we go after the witch Queen
do we go after the health motion I could
just get this thing here
yeah and then what I'm gonna do way I
want this um healing Ward yeah with the
first one somewhere man it's somewhere
in here I don't think
yeah I don't really think it's gonna
matter
you should it'll pick up I feel like
once we take care of some of the one of
these hands it'll get drastically easier
okay
yeah that's the issue
all right
whether y'all want it get him see what
happens because she's outside see what
happened don't put the Healer one no put
the hell in words out oh yeah yeah yeah
go ahead oh I didn't mean
let me test before I uh
all right so that's gonna be too heavy
because it's not gonna come to me
so I don't think leviathan's gonna work
on it
okay
it'll work on the fingers
no it won't and when I try it on the
fingers it's too heavy because if it's
not too heavy it will come to me if it's
too heavy I go to it okay
but what I can do
is I can hit him I can't believe I used
to be here of course
yeah see too heavy
mm-hmm
you're gonna push right through us
yeah he hit you for six
so am I hitting him or am I hitting the
the hands you know the tennis has
changed just to see what he do
sure why not yes
we gotta learn
okay
you're supposed to go for the backstab
hahaha
back standing board
oh damage
should we go after him
hey we'll see what happens it might be
easier to kill him yeah it would be to
kill these hands
because they ill every turn
yeah we'll give it a shot I'm worth it
I'll work trying that experiment
Unleash Your wrath as soon as like the
hands in the sky
really
you would have to physically hit him
you also just physically hit something
because you ain't got no corner
six he's dead
listen we might as well just restart it
because we we made a couple of mistakes
I made a few mistakes
and then we didn't start with the song
resilience from jump
yeah let's yeah
because Grace just got here and
oh God yeah what's going on what's going
on
why did it
it patterns to that giant spider
it did yeah and then it went away
I bet you those hands grabbed them
addict I need a five-year membership for
your IOP chain back I have no clue what
you mean by that fam not even a little
bit
somebody talking about the Halo match
foreign
hey I'm the one that that scored that
that flag so I don't know about that man
no he wants the medallion
so you you want me to pick up addict or
you want me to attack the thing I can
pick myself up attack him
let's hit that dude with everything we
got
well in that case
foreign
see I feel
the person who um I I need survivability
so I'm gonna make myself Invincible for
three turns yeah I'm about to do the
same thing in a minute yeah it'll knock
me down now
I don't have that unfortunately
all right script
keep on shipping
that music is crazy
mm-hmm
how dare you
back again
hey attic let's go yeah he's thinking I
can't reach him from where I'm at now
get one of those leap cards
they said one
[Laughter]
he would move
he did right into me
buddies I don't think this will work but
it's at least worth trying
[Music]
to travel yeah
so at least we learned from a fact that
he can't we can't Leviathan Christy
cool things in other enemies
him Canada
taste my blood
yeah yeah they're about to destroy this
way nice nice nice nice you didn't get
hit
I booted
oh
got my whole what the hell out of there
Wally
oh and I'm frozen that's wonderful it's
a wrap dude
this cat is not messing around
he's not playing no games yeah
yeah and look at that like
what the hell let's see how much oh
great oh it's perfect this is perfect
fantastic run fantastic you want me to
pick up the card
oh it's a wrap
we'll just take the save and try it
again tomorrow
we cannot give up now
because Grace is over there bored as
hell
[Music]
just leave and don't save
it I was gonna say so is my wife
yeah
I like how many turns you get that
didn't get to go two times then he get
the smash
and smash like one of that special bull
smashed like four or five times
it's not playing he just kept hitting it
over and over yeah it's like he keeps
going until he kills it
oh
when you see his fist do that
that's all the time
yep
Florida
just go all out yeah just go all out
try everything that sounds like it
sounds like uh get attic wants to bounce
yeah I know but let's just die out yeah
yeah
if if we die it will save the the
checkpoint though
oh that's what you're saying
yeah right well look yeah we got the
checkpoint but I'm scared that if we die
it will update and we'll lose the
checkpoint yeah I think it may do that
it may do that yeah let's not risk it
let's call it it's better than that risk
it we got to save data we made a bunch
of little mistakes in the beginning all
right so I'm just gonna leave